ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Did you
know that Google offers plugins
for VS code and IntelliJ,
and that Google Cloud comes
with a powerful build tool?
In this video, we'll cover
developing and building
with GCP tools from IDEs
to continuous integration
and continuous delivery,
so stick around.
[THEME MUSIC]
If you've missed
the earlier episode
on developer and
management tools,
check out the first
link in the description,
as it discusses the Google Cloud
SDK and tools such as Cloud
Shell and G Cloud.
For those of you
building applications
deployed as containers on
Kubernetes, such as on GKE
or to Cloud Run, and would like
to spend more time writing code
instead of YAML
config files, then
you should really try
Google Cloud Code.
Cloud Code is a set
of ID extensions
for VS code and IntelliJ that
let you rapidly iterate, debug,
and deploy code to contain
a runtime such as GKE,
but also to other
Kubernetes implementations.
Under the covers,
Cloud Code uses
popular tools such as
Skaffold, Minikube, Jib,
and, obviously,
Kubectl, to provide you
with continuous feedback
right inside your code editor.
It also supports remote
debugging of your apps
while leveraging building
IDE debugging features.
As you get started
with Cloud Code,
you should try the
built-in template.
That will help you create a
Kubernetes application that
just works in seconds,
and then deploy it
to a Kubernetes cluster.
[? Oneclick, ?] but also
continuous deployment
to your local Kubernetes
cluster, is supported via
Skaffold for a tight
development interloop.
You can also decide to set
up your application that
runs on Cloud Run using
a stored template,
deploying your app to
Cloud Run, and looking
at the status of your live
applications resources.
Cloud Code will let you easily
switch between different
build profiles to
build containers
using your local
Docker installation
or using tools like
Cloud Build, which
we'll talk about in a second.
You can also edit config
files with auto completion
and linting for Kubernetes,
all with inline documentation.
With this feature, you may
actually start to like YAML.
Generating diffs between
local and remote config files
is another neat feature
provided by the tool.
Cloud Code lets
you view and stream
logs from any of your
deployments, pods,
and containers, as well as
inspect a cluster's resources
with a built-in
Kubernetes explorer.
This is not only about
container patched apps,
but also about making
the numerous Google Cloud
libraries available to you as a
developer straight in the IDE.
It is also about supporting all
types of development artifacts
without having to build
the container images,
thanks to growing
support for build packs.
Building and deploying
straight from your development
environment can be
very productive,
but it can also
feel a bit magical.
It is also not very well aligned
with DevOps best practices,
since it does allow
for automation
and can lead to errors due to
different build environments.
In order to decouple the
build and deploy process
from your development tools,
GCP offers Cloud Build,
a fully managed
CI/CD platform that
executes your builds on Google
Cloud platform infrastructure.
Cloud Build typically
requires a build config file,
a set of instructions
expressed in JSON or YAML
describing what tasks
need to be performed,
or simply a Docker file.
You can configure builds
to fetch dependencies,
to run unit tests, static
analysis, and integration
tasks.
You can also create
artifacts with build
tools such as Docker,
Gradle, Maven, and Bazel.
And finally, you can also
deploy these artifacts
to your preferred runtime
or artifact repository.
Cloud Build executes your
build as a series of steps,
each executed in a
Docker container that
is provided by Cloud Build, by
the community, or by yourself.
Google provides and
maintains pre-built images
called builders that you
can reference in your build
steps to execute your tasks.
Builds are kicked off using the
G Cloud CLI, the Cloud Build
API, or via some
pre-configured source
repository hosted on
GitHub or a Bitbucket.
In fact, Cloud Build
provides a GitHub app,
which uses GitHub events
to automatically invoke
builds on GitHub pushes and pull
requests, and view your build
results on GitHub
and cloud console,
all with seamless
authentication.
As part of a build,
container images
can be created and pushed
to Google Cloud registry,
and applications can be
continuously deployed
to Compute Engine, to Kubernetes
engine, to Cloud Functions,
or to Cloud Run.
Cloud Build does not need
to be about app source code.
Cloud Build can be
used in conjunction
with infra as code tools,
such as HashiCorp's Terraform
or with third party
developer tools
such as JFrog's Artifactory.
Now that you have a truly
versatile build and CI/CD
tool, and plugins for popular
IDEs, what are you waiting for?
I really can't wait to see what
you code and build with JCB.
If you like this video, please
like, subscribe, comment,
share, and look forward to more
Google Cloud Essentials videos.
[THEME MUSIC]